how do you do it right how do you fight
the machine correctly and show people
there is a way out of this morass of
insanity uh well first here's a tweet
from ron desantis this is from two or
three days ago
he said last week the biden
administration requested the assistance
of state national guards to deploy at
washington d.c i have rejected this
request there will be no florida guard
sent to d.c for biden state of the union
now this was obviously right before the
state of the union and biden wanted uh
all of these national guards to show up
and they put fences all over the capitol
and they wanted this big army basically
to be there to scare the people now
meanwhile nobody was there did you see
any videos did i miss anything guys were
there any videos of mobs outside of the
capitol saying job items mean
no but they want to show you they have
power you don't have power so desantis
said hey i'm the chief executive of this
state this is complete fabricated
nonsense you're trying to make it seem
like you're under threat because you
guys love being victims or at least
having people perceive you as victims
and i'm just not going to play the game
so it's absolutely spectacular
absolutely spectacular and speaking of
spectacular um
last week was uh national margarita day
a very important day for me
and uh desantis had some fun with that
too so my advice to everyone out there
who's frustrated sad angry pissed off
feel those emotions go to a kickboxing
class have a margarita do whatever you
need to do this weekend and then wake up
on monday morning we gotta keep fighting
having a margarita is well and good but
it is not a cure for bite inflation
okay little cheesy whatever maybe he
should have actually drank from the
margarita right there but you see the
point they ruin everything sake you
you've ruined the world as we knew it
and then it's like no go out there and
have them read it
it's like biden is the one that has
ruined this when i was listening to
desantis speech last night he was very
clear in how biden's policies have
increased inflation how they have harmed
the
supply chain how they have screwed us up
in terms of energy right now by closing
keystone and more so that we are now
watching gas prices go up and prices of
everything actually one of the people at
the event asked what i thought was a
really excellent question to desantis
about uh the house prices here in
florida because i can tell you with
someone that just bought a house house
prices are really high right so now on
one hand that's good because that means
more people with money are coming in
they'll hire more workers it's all good
but at some point you want you want more
competition so that house prices go down
and what he said was he said we're
actually in a bit of a bind right now we
have all of these new people coming here
so they're competing for a limited set
of houses and then even though there's a
crazy amount of construction going on
here in florida and i can assure you
when i walk clyde almost every house in
my neighborhood is being knocked down or
in some level of construction because so
many new people are coming here and and
i hope they they will vote the right way
and i'll do everything i can when i'm on
dog walks to make sure that they do
but he said there's not much we can do
at the moment at the state level in
terms of the cost of goods when a two by
four now costs four times what it cost
before so
that's an honest answer from a
politician like he can't control the
cost of everything
but what you can do as he said is we can
try to lower taxes as much as possible
we can try to give as many incentives as
possible for builders to come here and
build he said we don't just give cash
away we're not going to do that sort of
thing
but this all falls on the lap of joe
biden and the democrats who did all this
i'm sorry if that sounds partisan
but it's true
it's true
desantis continued a couple days ago at
cpac in orlando and the problem that we
face as conservatives is a lot of major
institutions in our country have become
infected with this woke virus you look
at academia do we even need to discuss
that their main objective now is to
impose an ideological world view on the
people that come through their
universities you look at corporate
america they're mentioning it they're
opposing voter id many of them make a
lot of money from chinese slave labor
but they don't want voter id in the
united states so they are engaging in
woke activism you look at our
bureaucracy and how totally off the
rails they have become in many different
agencies and it's not just limited to
people like fauci you have it across the
board where this has become a major
behemoth you look
at the corrupt and dishonest legacy
media in this country and what they're
doing to divide us and what they're
doing to prop up the regime they are not
in the business of telling the truth
they're in the business of spinning
partisan narratives to be able to
benefit their side they don't speak
truth to power they're defending the
regime in power and if you speak up they
come after you they'll smear you they'll
defame you all they do day after day is
concoct a blizzard of lies to try to
deceive the american people and make no
mistake that's going to intensify
leading up to november they're going to
try to think do anything they can to
relieve the blame off biden and to try
to fool the american people into keeping
democrats in office we're not going to
let them do it but that's what we're
facing and then maybe to top it off you
have big tech
here's where we're at when you have a
society that's veering away from the
truth
anybody that stands up and speaks the
truth will come under fire
you know what's funny as he said it's
all going to intensify as it leads up to
november the lights in the studio
actually flickered
it's a sign from the lord man
they've got all sorts of tricks up their
sleeves but you see why i did the show
the way i did it today because i think
everybody especially you guys watching
this right if we're roughly like-minded
and that's why you watch this thing it's
like i was kind of feeling depressed
sort of or not even exactly depressed i
was feeling just like dejected about
everything after the state of the union
because it was so
counter to the world as i see it the the
image that that guy put up of what the
world is was so
reverse of what we're all seeing and so
many people swallow it so
uh that's why i did the show the way i
did it today because i think it's
important to defend the people that are
fighting and trying to build something
properly and if we can all just
incorporate that in our own lives then
then we'll be in good shape
foreign